that was a look at the new movie about
her life so your new documentary is
called pretty baby so why did Nell feel
like the right time to make this is
because your kids are older because do
they know Upon A lot of them they do now
and they didn't uh before the
documentary and that was a mistake that
was a bad mommy moment for me because I
should have prepped them a little bit
more yeah
um but so much of the way we live our
life is so so compartmentalized you know
I'm not we don't live in L.A we we live
in the city we just you know they don't
really know a lot about I don't we don't
have we don't hang out a lot in sort of
they're not exposed to them they're not
exposed to it and they go to regular
schools and so I think I was protecting
them from a lot of that
um but also we were just living our
lives and I was just moms so you know I
didn't I didn't have all my movies on a
loop like a crazy old lady did you see
my words how funny your mother is oh
wait wait it's coming up you know and so
I think they I felt we've been asked
many times to do a documentary and they
just always either felt like
eat your Hollywood stories or where are
they Nows or songs tabloid you know
exploitation and
um George Stephanopoulos and Ali
Wentworth their production company and I
really trusted them yeah and they sat me
down and said we would like this to be
not just you this yes it's all me the
whole show but it's the exploration of
sort of sexuality in America because
it's way more than just you when you
watch it yeah it's about the
objectification of young women and
sexualization of young women and how did
that time what was accepted yeah and I
couldn't make any of the movies I made
now you couldn't make them so I thought
okay if I'm going to do this I'm going
to have to implicitly trust and I had
just archived all of my material my mom
kept everything so I had a room
chock-a-block full with like beta half
inch quarter inch like I've been around
that long that all the formats were
different oh my God and I
yeah everything and it opened up a whole
conversation between us that we didn't
amongst us that we didn't I don't know
if I would have had that's what I was
going to say because they didn't know
about the sexual assault right so did
they find out like viewing this my one
daughter did yeah and and I wow I how do
you bring it up again like yeah so let's
talk about yeah yeah no that's hard
that's a hard conversation in general
but what was it like afterwards though
because also I think it's a lesson like
it's a good lesson for your daughters
like for all women watching yes I mean I
think that's that is why I chose to
include it because I couldn't say that I
was doing a full you know authentic open
documentary and then not be coy about
that or hide that or not you know I I
needed it to be just honest and also a
teaching moment or an opportunity to
have a conversation and my older
daughter actually I was privy to to the
incident
um my younger daughter wasn't and then
that was another whole thing how come
she knew and I didn't know and yeah and
I you know I was trying to say but look
how healthy we are and I am and I'm not
a victim and this stuff happens it's
been happening it can't that's the most
remarkable part can I point that out
it's the most remarkable thing I was
talking with my executive producer my
manager um this morning and I was like
it is incredible watching this
that you did turn out so like sane and
like not on you know a lot of child
actors especially going through what you
went through and it exposed to things
that you were maybe uncomfortable with
and didn't know to say no and like
didn't even know what was happening like
a lot of those people go down the line
of drugs and alcohol and like rehab and
like you know those people die young
like let's be honest like so it's
remarkable how amazing you are and like
how just even you are like a balanced
thank you yeah I think it's in it's
incredible thank you and I also think I
love that you said it you know I don't
carry the victim mentality like it's not
not a victim you're a survivor of
something and it's how you move forward
through these things in your life and I
you know I I do attribute a lot to my
mother because she did keep me out of
the Mania
um and you know it that was the Paradox
she put me in certain situations and
that people had a problem with and I
understand that yeah and then the flip
side is I was really protected in a very
interesting way and she was such an
enraging alcoholic not a rager but a
very hardcore alcoholic and my whole
Focus was keeping her alive
so I had this weight that should not be
on yeah absolutely I mean there's that
one moment where I stick up for her and
and you know it's the way the Press
treated us and what was acceptable
whether it's you know asking me my
measurements on Nationwide television
asking me to stand up Barbara Walters
did that and compared herself to me and
just the sort of the approach that they
had in asking me questions as a 12 year
old was really just unconscionable and
to see that it like stars rage it it
does it does I mean as a mom too I it
just breaks my heart to see that little
girl but you know I went to regular
schools I went to college I always had
this knowledge that if I don't have
something that's going to keep me
grounded I'm going to get eaten up by
this business I'm going to just get lost
in it and it's gonna it's going to
obliterate me and then what will I have
and I knew I needed something grounding
I knew I needed maybe that's what I
saved you is stepping outside of doing
something more normal and just seeing
another world and not and and and being
being a kid you know the having that
sort of experience and then I also
wanted to win
do you know what I mean I wanted to
prove to other people but to myself that
you can't I'm I'm right here and I have
grown into this person and I'm like a
Weeble You're Not Gonna Knock me over
yeah you know and yeah I'm right back
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
bye
[Music]